[Music]
you're doing so well
you are doing a new movie the intern and
you are starring in this movie with
Robert De Niro yeah I find that just
mine when we have a picture from the
sets you and De Niro like you're
bothering him in a bus stop you know
yeah I look like an aggressive teen yeah
let me get a selfie what what does he
make of you what is Robert De Niro the
great well make of you he's so cool he
doesn't laugh really maybe just doesn't
get funny but he he doesn't really
laughs II can't he just gives you a
DeNiro face you just gives you like a
and then hold just to Justin to see the
scope and then point to you like but
that's his reaction to everything is
yeah seeing a Thanksgiving turkey a
sunrise and it's everything I believe it
I don't know he just does this guy he
just does it like I finally started to
figure out like because I really wanted
to make him laugh you know because I'm
needy yeah and I was laughs and then I
realized he doesn't have a laugh that is
his laugh he's just like a and I'm like
that's maybe DeNiro can't Wow yeah maybe
maybe is the worst laugh there may be
lobsters
through this whole thing this whole vibe
that would ruin everything you had opted
the the shimmy yeah and the power frown
you pulled the power Fran it's a real
power frown I like it I like it
you shot you shock season 2 of Adam
Devine's house party you shot this one
in New Orleans yeah now that has got to
be a fun place to have a comedy shoot
yeah it was the best it was so much fun
I didn't gain 15 pounds in my neck you
did was I did it spent at it was the
whole goal going down there but it was
really cool everyone's very talented
down there but I think a lot of people
slip through the cracks because you
there in New Orleans and you think
they're talented I like I was watching
this dude on the street and he was just
boom what did that with this key but
they get good to meet both and and then
I'm like watching him for 20 minutes
like this guy is fantastic and then I
realized oh this guy sucks he's a
homeless crazy person but since he's in
New Orleans I'm like yes give me more
people to be b'doop whatever what a
talent yes he said meatball in there
three times
you